Hello.
Welcome to my session today.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
securing
the
continuous integration and delivery infrastructure
for the Tinkerbell
project.
My name is David Mackay,
and I am a senior developer advocate for
Equinix Metal.
I am also a CNCF ambassador,
and I do quite a lot of live
streaming. You can find my streams at Rawkode.live.
My goal with streaming is to provide educational
resources for all of us to learn the
vast cloud native landscape together.
And today, wanna introduce you to Tinkerbell, a
bare metal provisioning system open sourced by Equinix
Metal, now a CNCF sandbox project
that aims to solve some challenges
that have been difficult for a long time,
and that is commoditizing bare metal,
which is no easy task.
So before we dive right in, let me
just shrink myself down.
So Tinkerbell isn't your run of the mill
project. When we're working directly with the mill,
there are a lot of things that are
a little bit harder than working with virtual
machines.
First,
Tinkerbell has to run an in memory operating
system
that can handle partitioning disks, encrypting disks, writing
and installing operating system through container based workflows.
There's
multiple microservices
that are responsible for understanding which bare metal
devices are coming online through MAC address identification.
There is IPXC for booting the operating system
and streaming the operating systems over the network,
and, of course, there's IP address management too
in DHCP.
And whether you can use traditional CI systems,
you probably you definitely have to provide your
own runners.
So in order to build out our continuous
integration and delivery system for the Tinkerbell project,
we need access to some metal.
Personally,
I worked for Equinix Metal and Equinix Metal
do donate a substantial amount of infrastructure and
inventory to the Cloud Data Foundation for projects
like this.
My go to tool for spinning up
brand new machines on any cloud provider of
choice is Pulumi.
And there are a few reasons I wanna
talk about Pulumi
for this session.
One, Pulumi very graciously gave us a free
access to Pulumi Cloud for the Tinkerbell project.
This comes with a whole bunch of benefits.
From the security side, it meant that we
could commoditize access
through their RBAC system.
It also meant we could take advantage of
their secrets management as well.
Something that Pulumi does really well is allow
us to really adhere and adopt GetOps
by having everything that we need, including secrets
and the repository and pushed.
They are, of course, encrypted using the Pulumi
cloud
back end.
However,
if you want to use Pulumi and you
wanna stick to the open source, you can
use any Cloud KMS as a backend as
well.
And this is our actual production stack fail,
which is open source on github.com.
You can see we have AWS credentials here
and we also have our Equinix METL credentials.
And next,
it's not we can't just spin up METL
and magically does something. Right? We have to
go through some professional stage. So we need
some software on the devices too.
My go to tool for this is SaltStack.
Again, focusing on the security reasons of why
I'm using SaltStack is one, there's no SSH
as a transport protocol. SaltStack uses zero MQ
based messaging.
Pass messages,
which the minions are subscribing to from the
master and executing those states.
Salt also has a concept of pillars,
which allows us to have secret information available
on the salt master node and selectively distributing
the keys that we want to each individual
machine or menu based on a whole bunch
of grains and parameters.
One final thing about the messaging system here
is that it simplifies all of our network
policies. The minions only have to be able
to speak to the salt master. We're not
opening up ports for the salt master to
reach all of our minions, and that's a
big win too.
And the way that we are consuming
SaltStack or provisioning SaltStack on these machines
is leveraging Pulumi's secret store,
writing the secrets that we need to cloud
in it,
and then they'll come available to Salt.
And the secrets being stored in pillars means
that we can selectively distribute them based on
grain data to each of the menus.
So the menus only get the secrets that
we allow them to see.
And it's worth pointing out that
while Tinkerbell was open sourced by Equinix Metal
and a majority of the team comes from
Equinix Metal, that it is a CNCF sandbox
project.
This means that we're using hardware not on
our Equinix Metal accounts, but on our CNCF
accounts.
It also means that any maintainer or contributor,
regardless of where they where they are employed,
should be able to have the same amount
of access. We wanna protect against the bus
factor, of course, as well.
So we need to commoditize the access to
the machines.
And for that, I'm falling back on one
of my other favorite tools, Teleport.
Teleport allows us to disable
open
We don't need to rely
on giving people access to the machines
by
reaching out and getting their SSH keys or
scraping them from GitHub.
We don't need to add everybody to the
project on Equinix Medal.
We can use Teleport's SSH server,
which is backed by GitHub SSO,
and restrict access to these machines based on
a group that we create within the Tinkerbell
organization on GitHub.
So in order to give people access to
the runners or to the salt master itself,
we just have to add them to a
group on GitHub,
and that's pretty cool.
We're keeping teleport secure by only allowing private
IPV four access for other nodes to join
the cluster.
And again, the tokens are all stored in
the Pulumi store or encrypted by Pulumi and
distributed via cloud and to SaltStack to the
runners as needed.
So what does that all look like?
Okay.
So first, you can see all of the
code to provision this infrastructure and the applications
running on top of the machines at github.com/tinkerbell/infrastructure.
We have the Pulumi directory, which is responsible
for running the Pulumi app, provisioning the bare
metal, rating everything that we need to cloud
in it to self bootstrap the SALT setup.
From there, SALT takes over and installs everything
else that we need on itself
and the runner devices.
Using Pulumi's cloud, we have access to see
when Pulumi commands were run against a stack.
We can just click on Tinkerbell infrastructure production.
We can see the outputs.
We can see the configuration used, including the
secrets,
although they are nicely sophisticated.
And what else is cool is that we
have the activity view that shows us every
time someone ran the Pulumi stack. So we
got really good visibility into when any of
these secrets were accessed, the state was changed
and nodes were spun up.
Now in order to get access to the
machines, we can browse to teleport.TinkerBuild.org.
There's only one option to log in, and
that is through GitHub.
I click the magic button, and I now
have access to all of the machines within
the infrastructure.
I think what is really cool about Teleport
as our SSH means
is that we can have the ability to
see active sessions. And in fact, we can
even join them if they were in progress
and see what the people are typing or
doing or whatever.
And the sessions are also recorded.
So let's take a look at that.
We can jump on to our salt master,
and I can just run a nice simple
salt command to ensure that all of my
devices are online.
If we pop back over here,
we can click on active sessions, and we
can see that I have an SSH session
in progress.
And I have a join button,
which if I type echo,
hello,
I can see both of my terminals.
Very, very cool.
Let's end both of these sessions.
Hit refresh, and that'll end in just a
moment. Hopefully, it shows up here.
And now our session is gone.
We can go to our audit log. We
can see that sessions were started. We can
see the single sign on from GitHub.
We can see that someone joined a session,
and we can see the user disconnected.
We can come back here
and click play on a recorded session and
see all of those commands that were executed.
We got the cell we have the cell
test dot ping
followed by our echo.
Thank you for watching this session.
I hope you get as much value out
of Pulumi, Solstack, and Teleport
as I, the Tinkerbell, and Equinix.
A great day.